el sábado pasado una delegación de
washington visitó caracas pese a que
biden no reconoce a nicolás maduro pero
hoy el acercamiento fue con moscú en su
opinión para que se reunieron la
canciller del xiv rodríguez y sérguei
lávrov es una negociación indirecta o es
venezuela tan valiosa por su petróleo
que puede elegir entre los rusos o los
estadounidenses
no venezuela no es tan valiosa
energéticamente como lo fue en el pasado
encuentro de ver si rodríguez con lávrov
va un poco en la línea de poder
informarle de cuál fue la intención de
lo que se habló allí en miraflores
además de eso seguramente de avalar y
darle un espaldarazo a rusia y por
supuesto recordar que en rusia hay
capitales de venezuela tanto las
instituciones como por ejemplo pbs como
también de particulares vinculados al
gobierno a nicolás maduro por el cual la
gran pregunta y la gran incógnita será
qué va a pasar con esos capitales que se
encuentran en este país y es parte de
los temas que seguramente ha conversado
por otro lado del presidente colombiano
se reunió con joe biden como entra
colombia vecina de venezuela en ese
juego geopolítico
bueno eso es un espaldarazo que le da el
gobierno de eeuu a colombia y una forma
de tratar de dar un mensaje a venezuela
de que está en la zona de que eeuu está
descuidando su patio trasero y que tiene
un aliado muy importante como lo es
colombia pero bueno eso eso más allá de
cambiar un poco la la tónica y la
intención del acercamiento de washington
a venezuela no no lo cambien
y ya finalmente en ucrania le quiero
preguntar cree usted que los corredores
humanitarios van a funcionar
el gran problema de los corredores
humanitarios es que rusia está
imponiendo que
qué es esos corredores humanitarios sean
hacia el territorio ruso
y por lo cual ucrania dice que no lo va
a aceptar porque es bueno exponer
entonces en manos de rusia quienes están
atacando el territorio ucraniano yo creo
que esa negociación bueno tiene que
extenderse y que su cráneo lo que quiere
es que sus nacionales finalmente puedan
hacerlo guardarse en territorio europeo
y no en manos del agresor